qu'il soit blanc rouge sucré ou amer le
vin fait son grand retour en ile de
france
la jeune entreprise winery parisienne a
commencé à planter dans la plaine de
versailles en 2017
sur une superficie de 10 hectares trois
ans après c'est l'heure des récoltes sur
la parcelle en jachère depuis 15 ans
entretenu sans produits chimiques
on avait envie de vraiment bien étudié
les différentes parcelles qu'on a pu
voir par le passé pour trouver la
parcelle idéal pour développer de la
viticulture et du coup aujourd'hui on
est très satisfait parce qu'à dix jours
des vendanges tous les indicateurs
scientifiques nous montre que les
raisins sont mûrs que on va obtenir des
vins comment les avait imaginées qui
vont atypique de ce terroir qui va des
vins frais des gants avec un reste un
petit peu à part pour le premier
millésime l'objectif est de dix mille
bouteilles puis 150 milles dans quatre
ans un challenge pour redonner aux evil
sa place dans la production viticole
professionnelles françaises
pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental des yvelines
s'enthousiasme sur le développement du
terroir yvelinois on voit toute une
nouvelle génération qui souhaitent faire
de la transformation agricole ce qui est
très intéressant pour nos agriculteurs
parce que ça amène terme la valeur
ajoutée issue de l'agriculture dans le
département des yvelines c'est un
terroir c'est un terroir patrimoniale
c'est un terroir naturel c'est un
terroir cultiver chardonnay chenin pinot
noir et merlot sont attendus en 2020
l'opportunité aux yvelinois de re
découvrir les cépages incontournable sur
un nouveau territoire